Now that you've jogged your memory a bit about these three types of models,
let's talk about some specific examples that fit each of them. We're going to
look at a pretty wide variety of topics. Population growth, carbon dating, and
sound. Now earlier on in the course, we did talk about population growth, but
we did this with pandas. Now we're going to do it with humans. Now there's
pretty great data out there about how many people there are in the world. And
we're going to check this out all the way from 1800 up through 2011. Let's take
a look at some numbers. So here's a chart showing how the world population has
changed in those 200 plus years. In 1800 there were only 1 billion people. And
by 2011 there were 7 billion. Let's take a look at what this looks like on a
graph. Looking at how this data is plotted, what kind of model do you think
that this fits best? Does this look like exponential growth? Does it look like
exponential decay? Or does it look like logarithmic growth?